aaron rodgers another super honk he's
fancy to super hunk around i know he's
not your style based on the face you
just made wow uh the listeners if you're
watching on fox nation you just saw
something else emily just threw a
challenge flag they have to review
i object i go aaron rodgers now there's
a real super hunk and emily goes
wow
well anyway aaron rodgers this is what
happened and i think it's fascinating
he has tested positive for covet and of
course we wish him well um nothing but
the best but he's in an interesting
situation because he had told the league
he was vaccinated but he wasn't
vaccinated he got what he considers to
be a homeopathic treatment uh and when
he was asked by reporters are you
vaccinated he actually said the he
actually said the words i want to get
this specific term right john do you
know what it is he goes
i am inoculated
immunized yeah
which reporters took to say oh he
doesn't know how to say inoculated he's
saying i'm immunized i'm vaccinated when
in fact he wasn't vaccinated so he has
spent the better part of the last four
or five months on nfl sidelines not
following vaccine protocols
uh and now he has in fact gotten coveted
but what i guess i'm trying to ask you
emily
is we now living in an age where we used
to chalk our bars to get into we used to
chalk our id to get into bars you know
what i mean people would like you'd
borrow your sisters to say you're 21.
is that going on now like are people
like almost like chalking their vaccine
to get places in life like do you think
people are faking being vaccinated
beyond aaron rodgers like is he
symptomatic of something else going on
in society right well first of all yes i
was literally 27 in college as an 18
year old because i had my oldest
sister's idea it was brilliant it was
brilliant it clearly it worked and
that's why i'm hooked uh secondly yeah
absolutely and in fact we're seeing
widespread fraud that's been prosecuted
on the criminal level of people who
exist in realms of law enforcement uh in
in the medical field and more which are
making a living frankly a good
livelihood based on black market
vaccination cards but i think what's
interesting to me
is the notion that this is the carve out
exception to medical privacy so we sat
here a few years ago
or on on the side we sat a few years ago
and talked about do you remember when
jason pierre paul after july 4th right
had he had his finger
all of a sudden those records that was a
tremendous uproar because his hipaa
records were published on social media
and rightly so he was he he should have
had ultimate privacy medically and
professionally in that realm and that's
the bleed over into professional sports
like at what time does at what point
does your medical history or medical
choices sort of factor into the gambling
world the the performance world etc and
now with kovid that's a whole nother
layer where people feel absolutely um
inclined and they feel entitled to the
status of your vaccination so i think
it's interesting with aaron rodgers in
terms of like with people
literally having to do a complete like
what are those boards where they have
like the strings you know meeting
everyone it was close contacts but he
didn't wear a mask and then here he was
listed and like tracing it right because
at its heart right it's not technically
publishable or at least it's not readily
and yet people can infer or like deduce
where whether you're vaccinated or not
and now what he's getting the blowback
for is for quote misleading yeah but did
he and like i feel like to to us the
question is does the press equal
us
and do we equal his employers and should
there should those boundaries and
barriers be finkel is einhorn
i'm just ace-venturing what you said now
cause i know i get it it made sense
emily companion is in studio it's very
interesting that you say that because
i think right now
everybody does feel
like they are entitled to everyone
else's medical information and it's so
weird to me that it's like how we got
there as quickly as we did you know this
hasn't been an erosion over the course
of 20 years there's been an erosion over
the course of a few months you know even
with the mandate they were telling us a
few months ago i'm not going to have a
mandate were you crazy we have a mandate
it's pretty psychotic but to the iron
rodgers thing i still think you should
be allowed to play because as you you
follow the nfl and you know that the
chiefs defense that's who they're
playing this week has been socially
distancing from opponents all year
they have not been they've let up 220
points in like seven games how hard that
is to do
everyone is like scoring on the chiefs
but i get it and there's a protocol but
it's crazy because it's like it's one of
those things
you know where sports they can't nothing
can outrun
politics now you know and i don't even
mean from a protest level i just mean
because the covert thing has infiltrated
everything we've done how excited are
you going to be as a sports fan when
we're really back to consuming sports is
just purely sports booze heckling
cheerleaders games yo i miss that i do
and i don't know when that's going to be
because it seems lately that there's
always something preventing that purity
right first it was a certain political
agenda that we were seeing on the field
by the players that then resulted in uh
remember season ticket holders literally
sued over the right to enjoyment of
tickets i mean there was a lot going on
between the fans and the owners and the
league and the unions
and we saw it playing out on the field
we saw people boycotting with their
televisions and then now it's bled over
into covet and the like so there it
seems to be that there's always
something that's making people turned
off about the game rather than being
stoked about it um and i think you know
to your point about the readily like
just it just just like um just saying
the information i mean you told your
uber drivers in the elevator the other
day for 20 seconds with an elderly
gentleman and i asked if he minded if i
got in with him and he was like oh yeah
of course i'm vaccinated i presume you
are too you know and it was like yeah i
mean i i i give that private medical
information to strangers within four
seconds i wouldn't tell them my name i
wouldn't tell them anything and yet that
for some reason to your point is this
bit of information that we've like
scarlet lettered you know for for good
or for bad on ourselves
in an instant the world changed with
that and for those that feel a certain
way about it that want to have privacy
we sort of have potentially criminalized
or ostracized their right to privacy
frankly that was a right that we have
been um culturally
protective of and now all of a sudden
it's gone and now all of a sudden it
plays out on the field and now all of a
sudden it's written into league rules
man that's crazy you know coveted all of
a sudden it means a forfeit it means the
players pay penalties there are so much
going on that are affecting these guys
it's bananas and i just i want to end
so we can get back to boycotting jets
games for the regular reasons you know
what i mean